Let's discuss a typical DDOS
attack scenario by botnets.
First, the attacker
decides the victim and
when the victim machine
should be attacked.
In order to launch a DDOS attack,
the attacker must be able
to commandeer a botnet.
Here, we assume that the bots
already have the bot code,
and the bot code communicates
with the attacker regularly.
To start the attack,
the attacker sends the command
to all the bots in the botnet.
For example,
the command would tell the bots to send
connection request to
the victim at once.
The result is that the victim gets
connection requests from many,
many bots at the same time.
Therefore, the victim
is being overloaded and
the effect of denial of
service is accomplished.